صحيح في هذا اليوم يشتد القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على مختلف مناطق غزه ليس فقط في
المناطق الشرقيه ايضا في المناطق الغربيه
في هذه الاثناء قوات الاحتلال وقبل لحظات
اصابت ثلاث اشخاص في داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي بطلقات قناصه اسرائيليه الان ايضا
الطلقات القناصه الاسرائيليه تصل الى
مستشفى الشفاء الطبي وتتكرر هذه العمليه
الان حاله ذعر بين المواطنين في داخل
المجمع بعد وصول ط القناصه للمره الثانيه
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي في المره الاولى
اصيب ثلاث اشخاص والان يتكرر تتكرر
الطلقات وتصل الى هذا المكان من القناصه
الاسرائيليه علما ان قوات الاحتلال تتمركز
على على بعد امتار من هذا
المكان الطلقات تاتي وتصيب النازحين في
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي بشكل مباشر قبل
لحظات اصابت القناصه الاسرائيليه ثلاث
مواطنين داخل اقسام وبتحدي ديد داخل قسم
الجراحه التخصصي الذي نسلط عليه الكاميرا
الان خرجت الاصابات من هذا القسم بعد
اصابه القناصه الاسرائيليه للمواطنين
النازحين داخل هذا هذه هذا القسم الان
تخوف كبير بعد تكرار هذه العمليه علما ان
قوات الاحتلال منذ فجر هذا اليوم قصفت
الكثير من القذائف المدفعيه ووصل اليوم هو
يوم دامي بالتحديد الكثير من الشهداء الى
مجمع الشفاء الطبي هو يوم مختلف عن الايام
مسار الايام السابقه يزداد الق القصف
الاسرائيلي والقصف المدفعي على محيط مجمع
الشفاء الطبي ومحيط مستشفى المعمداني
بالاضافه الى منطقه تل الهواء ومختلف
المناطق التي يتواجد بها الاحتلال لكن وفق
المصادر الطبيه اليوم وصول الكثير من
الشهداء بطلقات القناصه الاسرائيليه
والقتل المباشر في مختلف المحاور التي
يتواجد بها السكان والنازحون في صباح هذا
اليوم قصفت قوات الاحتلال في منطقه
السنفور منزلا لعائله البطش وقصفت ايضا
منزلا اخر في منطقه الن نفق وكان هذا يدفع
لعائله اللوح الكثير من الكثير من الشهداء
وصلوا الى هذا المكان وحتى هذهه اللحظه
نتابع هذه التطورات بعد اطلاق قوات
الاحتلال الكثير من الطلقات الناريه على
محيط مجمع الشفاء الطبي و حتى على مبنى
مجمع الشفاء قنص اماكن في مجمع الشفاء لو
تحدد لنا اكثر احداثيات المواقع التي يتم
استهدافها من القناصه هل هي في المدخل
الرئيسي ام في ال الباب الخلفي كما كنا
نتابع سابقا يعني تحدد لنا
اكثر صحيح سنوجه الكاميرا الكاميرا الان
على اماكن تواجد الاحتلال في مفترق ضبيط
وهو على امتداد للبوابه الرئيسيه ل مبنى
الجراحه التخصصي وهذا المبنى الذي اصيب به
المواطنون في
داخله تتواجد قوات الاحتلال على امتداد
هذا الشارع وتتواجد القناصه الاسرائيليه
في هذا الشارع بشكل ملحوظ و و ومباشر
والجميع يعرف ان هذا المبنى هو يتبع لمبنى
الجراحه التخصصي الان وصول اصابات جديده
من اسعافات الى داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي لا
نعرف ماهيت هذه الاصابات لكن نعود الى
التحديد ب الى مكان وتواجد قوات الاحتلال
والسنه الدخان التي تتصاعد من اماكن تواجد
الاحتلال بشكل ملحوظ مع نهايه هذا الشارع
يتواجد الجيش الاسرائيلي في منطقه اليرموق
ومنطقه وزاره التربيه والتعليم ومنطقه
مفترق دبيد وهذا الشارع هو الواصل الى
مبنى الجراح التخصصي بشكل مباشر هذا ال
القناصه الاسرائيليه تتواجد في نهايه هذا
الشارع ومن هناك يمكن ان يطلق القناص تطلق
القناصه الاسرائيليه باي طلقات وتصل الى
هذا المبنى لكن اصيب ثلاث اشخاص وتابعنا
خروج هذه الاصابات من داخل مبنى الجراحه
التخصصي ويتم علاجها بشكل ميداني الان
وصول الاصابات ايضا تباعا يتم نقلها عبر
هذا الاسعاف ويتم نقلها داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي لا نعرف ماهيه هذه الاصابات ال هذا
هذا طفل ملطخ بالدماء ولا يمكن حي حتى
اتضاف السكان والنازحين في داخل هذا
المكان هؤلاء الجرحى الذين يصلون تبعا الى
مستشفى الشفاء من اين ياتون
تحديدا القصف الاسرائيلي في هذه المرات
يتركز في اماكن النزوح بشكل واضح
وبالتحديد في اي مكان يتواجد به نازحون
الان يتركز الان قصف مدفعي ايضا في محيط
المجمع لا نعرف هذه ماهيه هذه القذيفه
التي سقطت على اي من السكان او المواطنين
الذين يتواجدون بكثافه في المناطق الغربيه
الان ايضا بالتحديد تاتي هذه الاصابات
تباعا من منطقه من محيط منطقه تل الهواء
ومحيط منطقه الصبره التي يحاول النازحون
العوده اليها الان هذه الاصابه ايضا من
تلك المنطقه تاتي الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي
بعد عجز اصلا الكوادر الطبيه الكبير وصول
الى هذه الاصابات نعن نتابع من صباح هذا
اليوم اي اليوم الدامي والكثير من الشهداء
وصلوا الى هذا المكان اليوم على مختلف
الاصعده كل الاماكن يتواجد بها قصف كل
الاماكن الاماكن يتواجد بها قناصه
اسرائيليه يتعمد الجيش الاسرائيلي بقنص
المواطنين وقصفه بشكل مباشر لكن هذه المره
في المناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه التي عاد
اليها النازحون في منطقه تل الهواء ومنطقه
محيط او اطراف الزيتون هذه المناطق التي
تركز بها القصف الاسرائيلي ووصل الكثير من
الا اصبات من تلك المناطق شكرا جزيلا لك
من مستشفى الشفاء بمدينه غزه مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول